everybody and welcome to another Python
3 tutorial video in this video we're
talking about is read or regular
expressions so the idea of regular
expressions is regular expressions it's
it's own little programming language of
its own kind of like SQL or sequel or
whatever and the idea of of regular
expressions is to pass a string of
arguments that will apply to a string of
text basically so you're let's say you
have a body of text and you're trying to
figure out you're trying to pull some
data from it let's say you're trying to
pull like an R case what we're gonna do
is say we're gonna it's a paragraph and
we want to pull names and ages from the
paragraph and we're just gonna go ahead
and assume that names and ages are the
only like names would be the only
capitalized things and ages will be the
only numbers so the idea is you pass
data through or you pass like some
arguments basically through using
regular expressions saying I'm only
looking for let's say numbers too
you know we're looking for a two to
three digit numbers I guess with ages
would be one two three digit numbers and
then names we're looking for any string
where the first letter is capitalized
and then all the way to the end and then
if there's a space then that's the end
of it in whatever so the idea of regular
expressions is that another thing that
we're gonna use regular expressions for
very quickly is to parse paragraph data
away from HTML data in on websites and
stuff so if you recall the last bit last
video we visited some web sites and we
were able to get through their little
filters for robots but very quickly
we're seeing another problem is that we
can't figure out you know we're trying
all we really interested in is paragraph
text Billie's you know in theory that's
all we're interested in but we're having
a hard time separating all of that by
the program we've you go through
ourselves but it would take a long time
so anyways and the idea of in use of
regular expressions is they're extremely
useful it's definitely a good idea to
learn them
they're kind of intimidating at first
but they do get easier I promise so with
that let's go ahead and get started the
first thing is gonna be I'm just gonna
throw out some identifiers for you guys
and these are all things that you don't
have to memorize these from now I will
put first of all a copy and paste of
this in the description but also the
whole sample code I've been putting on
my sample code on Python programming
dotnet so you can also get all of the
sample code there as well so don't worry
about typing this out with me just kind
of if you want to type it out if you
feel like that helps you better then go
ahead and do it otherwise just kind of
listen and follow along it's not
necessary that you type this so
backslash will if you remember it's an
escaped character and when it comes to
regular expressions the backslash is
actually more of a notification that hey
this is a character pay attention so
anyway a little bit different than
normal but anyway so with regular
expressions a backslash lowercase D is
gonna be any numbers so this is how you
use begin and notify that hey we're
looking for a number and then you'll
you'll start putting in a description
but more on that you know in a little
bit the next thing we're gonna have is a
backslash capital D this is gonna be
anything but a number then you would
specify some more parameters but we'll
get there
backslash S is gonna be a space
backslash capital S anything but a space
okay
then you're gonna have backslash W this
is any character backslash capital W
anything you guessed it put a character
then we're gonna have a period now
period you know how to give it backslash
or anything for it so just keep in mind
that because of the period if you if you
want to designate like with regular
expressions you can all not only can you
search for things like this like any
number and a character or space you can
search for specific letters and the way
you would search for a specific letter
or a specific character which is just to
type that letter right so with a period
you can search as well for us
period or say you're looking for decimal
points you can do that but you actually
have to use backslash period so a little
funky there I think it's kind of silly
they did it but whatever so anyway a
period is any character except for a new
line so anything except a new line
next we have /b and the idea of /b is to
kind of make things easy for you we
weren't using an equal sign so just do
this
/b is the white space around words okay
so there's a lot of regular expression
that might go into coding you know
you're looking for white space or round
words so that luckily they've done it
for you
and then finally just as we said
backslash period okay a period okay it's
so I really don't understand I think
that these two should be flipped but
they are not so just keep that in mind
next up so those are identifiers then we
have what are known as modifiers and our
modifiers are basically like our
identifiers say hey we're looking for
any number then we have modifiers that
say hey we're looking for this amount of
numbers or this type or you'll get it in
the moment but basically we're modifying
any number and then we give a
description that's like our modifiers is
our description so we'll come down here
and for modifiers for example you might
have some brackets 1 and 3 so remember
before we were saying if we're looking
for age we're looking for an age with a
digit you know maybe one digit two three
digits so in this case this is you would
say this is a description four digits
let's say and we would say we're
expecting one two three of them okay so
for example this would be /d
one two three okay that would be we're
looking for digits one two three in
length well we get that next up we're
gonna say plus plus is means match one
or more so if you put a plus by
something it will only match if there's
one or more of them you put a question
mark it's gonna match zero or more now
why might you care about this this will
result and we'll never mind well maybe
we'll explain that later asterisk is
just going to match oh I'm sorry I did
this wrong let's see one or more match
zero or one then match zero or more so
there's a slight difference between this
and this and then also this this or this
right why might you only want to match
one you might only want to be finding
one instance you might not want a whole
list but anyway with more on that a
little bit now the dollar sign that's
gonna match the end of a string then
there's a caret sign this is matching
the beginning of a string so say you
were looking for pronouns you might not
want to look for anything at the
beginning of a string because everything
at the beginning like say you're
definition of a program is a capital
letter then if you're looking at the
beginning of the string you would get a
lot of false positives because
everything at the beginning of a
sentence is gonna be capitalized so then
we have the bars right so you've got
this little bar here and that matches
either or so you could say I'm looking
for a digit 1 2 3 in length oops right
and then you could have something like
this or I'm looking for a character 5 to
6 in length or does something like that
so that's where that bar might come into
play so it's either/or
then we have square brackets and these
just correspond to a range or variance
then we have these well you've already
seen the curly braces but you can also
have just a single number so you can say
five we're expecting five of these bits
of data so for now X expecting X oops X
then we can have what we did up here
that's X to Y so right expecting one two
three so speak the next one that we're
gonna do is they're called white let's
make some more space white space
characters these are characters that you
might may not necessarily see at least
in code but they exist so you've got new
n for new line we've already covered
that
backslash s for a space backslash t for
tab backslash e for escape you'll
probably very rarely ever seen that
backslash F you'll rarely see this too
for our feed and backslash R this is
return a carriage return you're probably
not gonna see that either these three
are the really the only ones you're ever
gonna really deal with but just so you
know the others do exist and maybe some
of you actually do need them hmm
now this will be a don't forget these
are the following characters so if you
recall there's a lot of symbols here
and another kind of confusing thing here
there's a lot of special things that we
have to remember so we're just gonna
list them out so a period plus sign
asterisk question mark brackets dollar
sign caret symbol
round braces curly braces
a bar and a backslash basically if you
really want to use these you have to
escape them so just keep that in mind
okay now the last thing I really want to
cover I suppose are I don't think yeah
we did range in variants but I guess I
should cover an example of range so
generally when you're gonna see square
brackets the what you're gonna see is
the following so it's gonna look what is
happening okay so a range you're gonna
see the following so if you've ever
looked into regular expressions you'll
probably recognize what I'm about to do
so a range might be A to Z okay so
you're looking here for capital A to Z
and then what you might see is like a to
Z like that and then you might also see
a Z like that as a first letter and then
a to Z has the second letter like that
the other thing to you you could see is
something like these are kind of
confusing let's say we do you're looking
for a number 1 to 5 with the lowercase
anything a 2q followed by an uppercase
anything a 2z okay it's got a little a
little confusing it's possible to do
that now
personally I rarely use code like that
to find what I'm looking for
just like with anything programming
there's many ways to satisfy the goal
whatever that goal happens to be but I
just want to me obvious what that kind
of means sometimes you're gonna see
regular expressions and you're in how
don't even understand what he's saying
and I took that tutorial so anyway
moving right along do we ever close off
this massive comment we sure did so
let's come back up here mm-hmm
we'll do that again don't have to worry
about copying this I just kind of wanted
to run through everything give you guys
kind of a get your feet wet and now
let's actually try what we've learned so
now you can start coding along with me
so to use regular expressions you have
to import the module as part of your
standard library and to import it you
just do import our e now let's make an
example string so we're gonna say
example string equals and then we're
gonna make it a multi-line string and
we're gonna say the following
jessica is 15 years old and Dan
Daniel is 27 years old okay then
Edward is 97 and his grandfather
Oscar is 102 okay
so we have this example string now what
we want to do with his example string is
we want to pull all the names and we
pull all the ages from the string
luckily in English at least we would not
say 15s Jessica you would always say
Jessica is 15 right and then you might
have a question like who is 15 Jessica
in that sense 15 would come first but at
least here for a missing example age is
always following the name so we can
always assume that name age and those
are the corresponding values so anyway
we're trying to pull names ages also we
don't have any capitalized letter or any
capitalized words that aren't names so
yay for us anyway so now what we want to
do is we'll come down here and now we're
gonna specify the regular expressions
that will correspond to names and the
regular questions that will correspond
to age so first we have ages equals
redefines all and to notify Python too
that this is going to be a regular
expression string use our then an
opening quotation and we'll go ahead and
close it all already and now we're gonna
say for ages
we know that following ages we've got
two digits two digits three digits but
it's conceivable there might be a one
digit age somewhere in there so we know
that we want a search force backslash D
so we're wanna search for digits and now
we want to say we want to find any
digits that are 1 2 3
so we use these curly braces and we'll
use one comma three done now that's the
first parameter you specify the regular
expression that you're in search for now
comma where do we want to search for
this string well we want to search for
it an example string okay next what we
want to do is names and names is gonna
equal read up find all again and we're
gonna say it's a regular expression
close that off already and names are
going to be the following now remember
before I did this this is basically
searching for any of those characters a
one two five and eight EQ or a capital A
to Z and you can do that and there's
also there's a couple other things that
you can do I think probably when I
worded this I probably worded it poorly
it's not one two five then at eighty Q
then eight is capital A to Z it's any of
the following
but anyway so we're looking for any
capital letter first so we're gonna say
anything capital A to Z we're looking
for first and then we're gonna look for
anything capital A to Z lowercase and
then asterisk okay and that asterisk is
basically saying we're looking for just
one of these but as many of these zero
more repetitions of those but that's
just a two Z's so as soon as we had a
white space a period comma anything it's
gonna stop parsing that so that's all we
have to do and again on example string
is where we want to apply this so now
what we can do is we can go print mm-hmm
ages and print names and let's save and
run that and see what we get okay so we
get Jessica fifteen Daniel twenty seven
Edward ninety seven Oscar 100 M 2 so we
get lists of this data we could also end
up putting stuffing these into a
dictionary so for each let's say if you
wanted to get fancy Dancy about it this
tutorial already pretty long anyway so
whatever well we could say for each
let's say
each name in names let's specify age
dicks up here equals empty for now for
each name in names age dicks each name
hmm
page dick each name equals I guess
there's a couple of ways we can do this
I think the easy first of all we could
do index and get the index number and
then go so we can do that or the easier
play that we can do this is we could say
x equals zero for each name in names age
dick each name equals ages x x+ equals
one that's it now we can let's see if we
print age dates and if that works out
for us yeah there we go
okay so then we get our dictionary and
so that's our output and we can check it
over here Edward not Jessica's 15
Daniel's 27 Oscar Edwards 97 Oscars one
or two okay so now we've populated a
dictionary with this with this data
right or you could have stuffed it into
a database or whatever
probably the superior way to do this was
what would have been actually to check
the index but when I did it was finding
it shorter so anyways that's gonna
include just an introduction to regular
expressions in the end we covered a lot
of the regular expression characters but
we didn't cover a lot of what the rd
module can actually do so the only thing
that we actually use with our e module
is redefined all there are other things
that we can do with regular expressions
so we will be covering more on regular
expressions personally I use some of the
other ones but redefined all is pretty
much the only one I ever use so that's
why I covered it I figured that maybe
that's what most people want but there
are other regular expression functions
and so we definitely want to cover
the other ones but now I can conclude
this video and then the next video we're
gonna be combining URL Lib and regular
expressions to parse paragraph data from
the website so anyway stay tuned for
that if you guys have any questions or
comments feel free to leave those below
if you have any requests for tutorials
that you want me to cover in the series
let me know as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time